on est dans cette guerre en mille
morceaux ces mille morceaux que va
réunir le soldat machin qu'est le verrou
de cette petite histoire il va les
réunir dans une caisse de munitions
allemandes à la fin du livre on sait la
petite surprise qui bouclent pleurer si
le soldat machin c'est un soldat moyens
qui ressemble à tous les autres
à l'époque la france rurale il est bien
sûr issu d'un petit village et comme le
raconte la légende le cliché je dirais
bien il était en plein champ en train de
travailler quand le tocsin a sonné qu'il
est allé avec ses copains ses voisins
les autres fermiers
lire la grande affiche qui
était pas garder devant sur le mur de la
mairie et qui disait demain c'est la
mobilisation
donc on compte ses copains qui jouent de
l'harmonica puis celui qui grave est le
portrait de son papa rester en algérie
parce qu'on parle aussi bien sûr de cv
de ses soldats la venue de tellement
loin et le soldat machin il va retrouver
une vraie identité parce que il va avoir
la chance de sauver sa peau et de
retourner au village je l' ai aussi fait
vivre grâce aux objets que j'ai réuni
voilà une dizaine d'années je me suis
passionné pour ces objets que je trouve
des documents historiques extrêmement
parlant pour les enfants chaque fois que
j'en montre à des enfants ils sont ils
se sentent très concernés
si ç'avait été le seul ouvrage depuis 20
ans aux éditions rue du monde qui avoue
que cette question aurait été
opportuniste mais il se trouve elle a
fait une bonne dizaine bonne douzaine au
fil du temps qui essaie d'éduquer les
enfants à la paix avec nos amis
daeninckx perf des grandes signatures
la littérature jeunesse notamment
[Musique]